foreign
good morning everyone
you will be unsurprised to hear that i
believe tom tukandart should be our next
prime minister
tom and i met in 2015 on our first day
as mps
since then i've got to know him his
family
those who he served alongside and our
shared outlook in the world has turned
out to be very similar like me he is a
conviction politician
unashamedly willing to stand up for what
he believes in and to kick down doors to
make things happen for his constituents
for his country and for our global
family
his leadership record over a decade
serving in the military
playing a vital role in the
reconstruction in iraq just to name but
one area will shape our outlook as the
uk on the world stage and at home
and while putin's illegal invasion rages
on the people of ukraine look to
reconstruction and i know that tom's
commitment to continuing our uk
leadership in rebuilding lives homes
roads and infrastructure will be
unwavering
and we also must look to crack on with
the maximization of the benefits of
brexit everywhere i travel in the world
countries want to do business with the
united kingdom they want our products
and our services they want our culture
and our values
but you know what for too long we have
done ourselves down as a country so it's
time for a fresh start and i know that
tom will champion great britain and
northern ireland and the businesses that
make us world class he will make the uk
once again the best place for businesses
to invest and
closer to home over the next few months
we are going to be faced with some tough
decisions i know that tom will steer the
nation through the storm seizing the
global opportunities brexit has given to
grow our economy
he is the person to unite our party
and our country with a clear vision to
enrich lives across every part of our
great nation
so i'm backing tom for prime minister
for four reasons
first his ambition for the future of the
uk backing britain on the world stage as
we forge ahead with our world trade
deals and the reforms still needed to
make brexit the springboard to the uk
success that i campaigned for
second his bravery in making difficult
decisions that will need to be taken
tackling the cost of living sorting out
nhs backlogs primary care and growing
our economy
third his commitment genuine passionate
commitment to protecting our great union
and last his drive to deliver for every
person in this country and that starts
with our economy
it's time for a fresh start it's time
for a clean start it's time for tom
[Applause]
well good morning
it's very good to see you
welcome
families across the united kingdom
are facing a moment of crisis
it's becoming harder
for people to simply get by
for so many
there is more month than pay
and we're facing danger abroad
division in our politics
an economy saddled with debt
and a creeping sense of despair
about our collective future
this is a defining moment for us
it's a defining moment for our country
it's a defining moment for our party and
it's going to test the values on which
we stand
i'm going to talk about economic policy
today
but for me for conservatives
leading on the economy is not
only a question of policy
it's a question of values
it's a question of mission a question of
our task and our purpose
we have been charged with the mission of
advancing the interests of the british
economy
and the british people
they have asked us to hold ground for
them
to secure the possibility of prosperity
for each of them
they have asked us not only to hold the
line
but to advance their aspirations
to move them and their children
more confidently into the future
to hear them
and to respond to them
and most importantly to serve them
advancing all of us
towards a future
with a fairer stronger and more
resilient economy
they've asked us to advance
and yet
we have retreated
in a moment that is so desperate for so
many
when our service is most needed
we have retreated
we have retreated into the pettiness of
politics that is more about personality
than principle
we have retreated into division
when we desperately need unity
when our nation needed our party to
function
we retreated into faction
when the moment demanded service
we delivered scandal
this is a crisis of purpose of
leadership
and of trust
we have been divided and distracted
when we need to be united responsive and
committed to our future
and to the future of our people
i'm sorry
but i cannot accept retreat
we should not accept retreat
we must return to service
we need leadership
with a renewed sense of mission
leadership that sees beyond divisive
politics and delivers results
leadership that will return government
to the service of our economy our people
and our country
we need a clean start
for me
that is much more than just a slogan or
a catchphrase
it's a mission statement it describes
our path forward together it summarizes
our advance orders
for the next decade
it allows us to move forward together a
fresh optimistic enthusiastic
confident
post brexit
and ready to seize the moment the new
that is why i'm introducing my ten-year
plan for growth it will return our
government to the service of the british
people and the british economy
it will make our economy stronger our
society fairer
and
make our country
more resilient
and it will do it by returning to the
core values that unite us all as
conservatives
i believe in liberty and the low taxes
necessary to defend it i believe in
responsibility
and the honesty essential to delivering
it
and i believe that with a clean start
and with a return to service
we can ensure the prosperity of homes
and families in every part of the
country
stronger
fairer
and more resilient
i believe that a clean start
that returns us to the service of the
people will produce a brighter future
our economy should be advancing not
retreating
yet millions of people
are opening bills with dread
not knowing what they'll have to cut
to pay for what they need
they're filling up their car
wondering what it will cost to get to
work the next day or the next month
and every day
families are seeing their savings
being steadily eroded
and wondering
will this be over by christmas
this just isn't sustainable
it's not fair
it's not right we must act
like all conservatives
i want people to keep more of their own
money
i believe that we should cut the cost of
government wherever we can
but this isn't an auction i'm not here
to bid for the highest or the lowest on
every tax policy
i'm here to make the case that our
economy can only prosper if we believe
that people not westminster
know best how to spend their money
i know the pain that families are
feeling now
and that is why my first pledge
is to take fuel duty down by 10 pence a
little
my second
is to reverse the national insurance
rights
now this isn't about percentages
it's about jobs
it's about families it's about workers
that's why i didn't vote for the
increase then
and i wouldn't do so now
but that's not enough
we need to go further
i want to ensure
that we cut the right taxes and get the
right results
our investment incentives are amongst
the worst in the oecd
that means that it's less attractive to
invest in the uk
than it should be that fewer businesses
by machinery train their staff
and plan for the long term
now economists call that productivity
and they tell us
that we don't have enough of it
what that really means
is that we don't create enough
we don't create fast enough
we don't sell well enough
now that means that every hour
british workers
are not getting the return on their
effort
that they should
and people across our country
are losing out
we can fix it
businesses can invest more in technology
and training
to drive up real pay not inflation
but they can only do it if we change the
incentives and that means making it
cheaper for customers to invest in their
future
that is why i'm committing to ensuring
businesses have the certainty they need
to invest for the long term
by introducing a program of permanent
full expensing
giving firms the confidence
they need to plan for future growth
the united kingdom under my leadership
will have the most investment friendly
tax system in the oecd within five years
but let me make clear
tax cuts
cannot be the only round in the magazine
my 10-year strategy for growth goes
beyond taxes
what we need
is deregulation
to allow companies to thrive
not because all regulation is bad a
market needs rules and a way to enforce
them
but technology moves fast
and often outpaces the regulators
so even when well intended rules can
become stifling
we need to find ways to change them
we need regulations that serve the best
interests of our people and our economy
and those written for a different time
and a different order
need particular attention
i want to seize one of the biggest
economic benefits of brexit
that we haven't yet grasped
i'm talking about the eu's consultancy
two regulations
eu rules
that force british insurers to sit on
dead money
that they're not allowed to invest
i will urgently reform these rules to
bring these savings to life
employing people starting businesses
building homes and giving families a
chance
to be clear that will mean around 100
billion pounds of british savers money
that can be put to work
regenerating our communities
and building homes
that's dead money
breathing new life into our communities
the truth is that the last government
hasn't moved far enough or fast enough
we need a clean start to bring energy
and determination and on this we need to
escape the eu's regular regulatory orbit
now
brexit has given britain the chance to
do better and i will deliver
that's how we will harness this
country's full potential because talent
isn't exclusive to telford brainpower is
no greater in brighton and i can tell
you
certainly from my position on the green
benches
iq in islington is certainly not higher
than an inverness
what that means is that an economy which
would neglect places
doesn't just neglect people
it neglects an opportunity for prospect
for prosperity for us all
the northern research group
talk about spanning the divide and about
ensuring that opportunity is spread
across the country i entirely agree
that is why
i will equalize funding across all our
regions
making sure that spending on innovation
infrastructure and transport
is spread fairly
so that growth can follow
a clean start
requires serving
all of britain
now my friend jake berry
speaks about wanting a vocational
oxbridge in the north he's right
i want one
in every region
that is why i will commit
to creating new institutes of technology
across every major town and city in the
united kingdom so that every child has
the chance for a world-class technical
education
leveling up
isn't about us and them it's not about
north versus south or east versus west
it's about harnessing the energy of the
entire country
to build a better future for everyone
now i have talked
about how to make our economy
stronger i now want to turn
to how to get a clean start
as we serve the goal of a fairer economy
now to a family
in newport
it's not about gdp
it's about gps
when a family gets ill
when we need help when we need support
we all turn to our public services we
know how important they are
but we also know they are struggling
and that means we are too
too many of us
are struggling to access the services we
need to see the doctors we want
struggling to feel safe and secure in
our homes
take the nhs
we're putting in
record investment without seeing the
outcomes we need
now i know
that even the best trained and most
dedicated teams need targets
take a simple measure
the four-hour a e pledge was last met in
2015. people deserve better
we expect better
i will deliver better
as a first and immediate step i would
reintroduce a binding a e and referrals
target and hold nhs leaders accountable
for it
but we won't just focus on the symptoms
on my first day as prime minister
i will bring together experts from the
nhs the wider public sector the military
the private sector and the voluntary
sector to bust through this
nhs backlog copying the success of the
vaccine task force that delivered the
first vaccine here in the united kingdom
before anywhere else
focus matters
delivery matters
competence
matters
finally
we need the kind of clean start that
will make our economy and society
more resilient
from cobit to the energy crisis we have
learned
that even if we get everything right
our country and our economy is exposed
to threats at home and abroad a
responsible government is one that plans
ahead that thinks about the future not
just the present
one that keeps the one that takes steps
to ensure that we are not vulnerable
and that those who try to harm us
fail
i've warned about this many many times
before about the vulnerability that we
face in our supply chains and our energy
we all remember the desperate times
when we rushed
to secure protective equipment on far
away runways
and we still found ourselves short
and we all feel the pain of higher oil
and gas prices now
that is why i will introduce an energy
resilience plan to ensure that the
united kingdom has dependable
power produced at home
or sourced from trusted allies
that's the only way we can truly protect
our sovereignty it's the only way we can
keep household bills low
it's the only way that we can keep our
businesses competitive
that means more clean energy
it means
more nuclear energy
and the capture and storage capability
to help reduce carbon
here in the united kingdom
it means
creating a strategy
to ensure
that we aren't dependent on china to
produce or process our critical with
minerals
or on hostile states for our gas
and it means working with our allies
to ensure that where we do import energy
we do not
compromise our values
or our alliances
that is the only way that we can tackle
the weaponization of our energy markets
by hostile states
let me say now
if we do not grasp this issue
we are giving ground to our enemies
who will ruthlessly exploit it
ladies and gentlemen
this great country of ours is at a
crossroads
we are faced with some of the most
daunting challenges at home and abroad
we need serious leadership
we need to tackle the cost of living
we need a 10-year
plan for growth
we need bold leadership
to deliver a return to service
i am ready to serve i am ready to lead
we need a clean start
thank you very much
thank you very much i've been asked to
take a question from the bbc i suppose
that's traditional
thank you um tom that was a very
detailed policy speech actually there
was a lot of uh little stuff in there
that uh that you wanted to announce but
how realistic really are you about this
uh bid to be leader uh given the
strength of the field and uh and also
the way that the contest is already uh
shaking out so is this really all about
just becoming foreign secretary in
someone else's government
and also if i might also ask uh if you
have any reaction to the bbc panorama
story that broke this morning uh about
the sas
killing unarmed men in afghanistan
let me be extremely clear
i did not enter this race for any other
purpose
than to champion the values that i stand
on
and to lead the country that i love
that is why i am here
this is not a compromise position this
is not a negotiating strategy
this is a plan
and we're going to deliver it
i'm going to say something else because
i think it's important
the conservative party is going to need
an election after this to hold our party
together
there is no way
that anyone who makes it to the last two
should either offer or accept a
compromise that goes behind the backs of
conservative party members
now you asked about the panorama story
i'm afraid i only heard a little bit of
it on the radio this morning so
let me answer
what i know
i know
that between 2005 and 2009
when i was serving in afghanistan
i met many extraordinary courageous
determined and brave people serving our
country
i know
that during my time in afghanistan i
neither saw nor heard any of these
accusations
and i know
that any investigation any accusation
will be investigated fully by the
ministry of defense
and that's not just because it's the
right thing to do
for the victims or potential victims or
alleged victims it's the right thing to
do for the british military
because we stand on our values and
standards as a country and the military
especially
is absolutely reliant on those values of
standards to maintain the ethos
and discipline in war that is essential
to victory
so i have absolutely no doubt that if
there is any truth
to these accusations
then the mod will sort it out
sam coats
mr teagan hat um first of all you just
talked about the need for an election
how soon would do you think there should
be an election are you talking about
cutting short this parliament down the
road in another leadership uh uh contest
launch it's incredible to believe that
there's more than one at the moment
dominick roberts just said that this is
no time to learn on the job he's right
isn't he and finally you opened your
speech by talking about britishness
we've also talked about being a dual
national you have a french mother what
have you learned uh from that by being a
jude nation sure well i think the first
thing i've learned uh about being a dual
national is that i should have chosen my
mother better
when i decided
to go into politics
there's only so many things i can change
sam that's not one of them
the reality is
that the
job of prime minister is unlike every
other job in government it's not a
management job
it's not a departmental job
it's a job that demands vision and
leadership
it demands
a willingness to serve
and throw everything
in the duty of serving the british
people
this is no time to learn
what this is is a time to look at a
record of service
a record of delivery
under the most difficult and trying
conditions around the world
and to see that this isn't learning on
the job
this is putting all that experience to
work
on the job
and the best job and the hardest job in
the united kingdom
there is
two years to go before a general
election at least now
there is no
mandate for an early one
what there is is a mandate for a new
leader
what we need is we need a new leader
to deliver and when i am prime minister
i will be rolling out a new deal for
britain
that will demonstrate
how we're delivering
before i go to the country and ask them
to trust us again because we need to
rebuild trust
we're only going to do it if we get a
clean start
and the right team around that table
thank you
andy
two questions some of you don't mind
firstly do you now regret voting uh for
remain in the referendum and secondly
what is the big difference between the
biggest difference between you and boris
johnson
i'm not sure i know how to answer the
second question i could
i could
i could start i could start quite a long
chapter in a book on that one
um i think what's important is to look
to the future not the past
i think the real challenge in the united
kingdom
is that while we've got
brexit done we haven't made brexit
deliver
and that's what i'm probably promising
to do
when i am leader of this country when i
am prime minister i will lead a
government that brings talent from
across the party
that recognizes
that however you voted in the past
does not mean that you're any less
committed any less determined
to deliver for all of our homes our
communities our families
of course you are
the reason my colleagues
stood as conservative members of
parliament the reason we are lucky to
have such extraordinary talent in our
party
at westminster and in council chambers
across the country the reason that the
conservative party is the natural party
of government is because we are a party
that prioritizes service and delivery
and that is exactly what we will do
when i am leader we will get back to
serving the british people and make sure
that the leadership of the party serves
the membership to deliver the values
that we all share
that's how i'm going to be prime
minister here
well as i say there are many differences
he had to pay a lot of money to hand
over his citizenship i'm not allowed to
give up mine
[Applause]
okay